I want to make sure I bring this up
because uh you worked with uh a comic
who fascinates me jacn Novak and she did
you directed an executive produced her
special get on your
knees and shot this at the Town Hall
theater in New York City and this is out
now um when this drops it'll be out so
it's out now and uh she's unlike any
other standup I don't want to even
categorize her she's just not like any
other standup I've encountered she is
incredibly literate and almost poetic or
I'm not going to say almost poetic a lot
of her language and imagery is
poetic she's a great performer yes uh
John meany uh said uh ladies and
gentlemen I've seen the Muhammad Ali of
Comedy um about jacqulyn Novak uh and uh
she is brilliant
like when she start when she got into
this kind of like um yeah like uh I
prefer calling uh doggy style the hounds
way I was like she's so she she's
talking a lot about uh well she's
talking
about about oral sex yeah sucking
them I'm sorry you took the words
right out of my mouth no problem you
took the right out of my mouth no
problem go Conan we're all going to die
so get those out of your mouth
yeah or don't you know what I
mean kind
of in your mouth you she's talking about
a lot of very graphic stuff but it's
almost like you're listening
to it's almost like it's Emily Brony
talking about it it's fascinating
because she's great she's great writer
as she keeps moving through the show
it's like yeah she does she goes full TS
Elliott she's like a patient etherized
on a table you know and so yes she's
talking about jobs but that is really
not what it's about so much more and
it's really kind of delightful to watch
I'm glad to hear you you took you took
very good care of her I mean that's you
you did a good job thank you um and I'm
sure that means a lot coming from me
yeah no so I just had to I had to put
that in I'm just cuz you wouldn't say it
so but I mean there's no higher praise
no I mean like to hear that from you
like in this
moment man you're good are you
kidding me
you right all those reviews on Criterion
Criterion con telling me that that
is good that's right criterian con
criterian con there's no better guy to
get a compliment from yeah no uh but
genuinely uh and uh hopefully um you
know uh your your your people um are
they followers is it a cult cult it's a
cult um I have certain as the cult
leader I have certain privileges yeah so
I'm I'm glad you've officially endorsed
it uh and uh you know remember that when
you click on um uh the special on
Netflix it's a it's really about a
completion rate that's how they sort of
do it the streamers so uh you can't just
click on it and watch five minutes it
doesn't really it won't help the Novak
you want to really uh click and watch
you know uh even if you got to do your
laundry or whatever you're doing in the
backr on your text messaging we just let
it play all the way that's how the
algorithm Works uh they need that
completion rate uh so just watch it
spoken like a true
artist watch it fast and
off send send money send tweets
okay